okay the GOP debate was last night um I
didn't watch the whole thing I can't
imagine why anybody would watch the
whole thing these days but you could
always go and find the important parts
after the fact um so there's no reason
to endure the whole uncut unedited
charade uh and you all know how I feel
about debates I I hate them I hate the
way they're conducted these days at
least um I I think in theory
presidential debates and president and
and U primary debates could be great
could be quite informative and and
interesting and edifying
but they aren't because they're
conducted in a way that is like
specifically designed to make them
useless and pointless and really really
they're conducted uh to give the
moderators opportunities to show off you
know the way debates are done now it's
really it's not even about the
candidates it's about the moderators
because every debate is hosted by a
cable news uh Channel or or a network
News Channel and all they want to do is
promote themselves that's all they care
about and that was definitely on display
last night so uh who won the debate well
do santis perform well definitely a
solid B+ performance the question is
whether Dan
santis you know for him whether anything
outside of an A+ is effectively an F at
this point because he needs big moments
you know not just solid moments but he
needs big big moments to to close the
gap um but either way it was it was a it
was a good performance uh Nikki Haley
there are some people that are saying
that she performed I thought she was
annoying um and half of the people on
the stage shouldn't have been there to
begin with if you're going to have Doug
bergam on the stage you might as well
have me I I have a significantly better
chance of becoming president than Doug
bergam um but the problem is that these
these debates are really just forums of
course for talking uh talking points
that we've already heard a million times
and for these kind of rehearsed
punchlines these things that are it's
never it's never in the- moment it's
never spontaneous we're not seeing
anybody's wit and intelligence put on
display because that would be something
just because somebody has wit and
intelligence doesn't mean that they
necessarily deserve to be president but
it's an important quality for a
president to
have um and if so if we could actually
see that put on display that would that
would be something but we're not seeing
that they they go in with certain lines
that their you know team has given them
and their consultants and everything
that oh you got to get get this line in
there this polls really
well and then they deliver it and it's
always incredibly clear they can never
even make it sound natural you can
always tell like you can tell even
before the line like whatever clever
line that they have they were fed by
their consultants and they were told
this will go viral this will be a good
one you before they even get to the line
you know that it's coming because
they're kind of they're winding up
there's this wind up before they get to
the
line and um
Chris Christie uh is kind of notorious
for this and uh here is his big line
that he wanted to go viral going after
Donald Trump let's watch that and Donald
Trump should be here to answer for that
but he's not and I want to look at that
camera right now and tell you Donald I
know you're watching you can't help
yourself I know you're watching okay and
you're not here tonight not because of
polls and not because of your
indictments you're not here tonight
because you're afraid of being on the
stage and Defending Your record you're
ducking these things and let me tell you
what's going to happen you keep doing
that no one up appear is going to call
you Donald Trump anymore we're GNA call
you Donald Duck all right I want to ask
Governor he's so impressed with himself
after he says that we're gonna call you
Donald Duck you hear that you guys hear
that you guys catch that Donald Duck
because he's ducking and he's and his
name is
Donald you
know yeah like the cartoon character
Donald Duck you know that guy that's who
I'm saying this guy's
like uh he really thought Donald Duck
was gonna land and it wasn't just him I
we can't just blame him these are
politicians they don't have any thoughts
in their head they have no original
thoughts all they don't think anything
they have nothing they have no brain at
all so they they're they're just given
so they had someone came up with this
and that person didn't come up with it
either actually that person didn't come
up with it they probably saw it on on
Twitter or something they saw a meme
calling Donald Trump Donald Duck and
they said that's a good one we gota we
got to give that
and this is what he came up with and I
mean it it's it's not going to work
anyway like first of all this is the
classic mistake that that many um failed
opponents of Donald Trump have made over
the years where they try to do the
nickname thing that Trump does but it
never works it never works to try to out
Trump trump you know you'd think
everyone would at least understand that
by now you can't out Trump trump and
there are things that Trump can get away
with
uh that other people can and one of them
is like the corny nickname all of
Trump's nicknames for other people
they're always corny they're corny as
hell but he kind he makes it work
because it's just a Donald Trump thing
he can do that it's not GNA work for you
you can't do that so if you are going to
throw the nickname in don't make it the
whole punchline like throw it in at the
beginning and then have something else
and maybe you make it work there so
maybe if he had said listen Donald Duck
let me tell you something and then he
had gone on to say something else you
know maybe it kind of
works but when you when you set it up
and everything is leading to that moment
and he's he's even he's set it up as a
threat he's like if you don't do it as I
say here's what's going to happen to you
I'll tell you what's gonna happen get
ready for this something real bad's
gonna happen to you here it is I'm gonna
call you Donald
Duck that's not the setup there's too
much setup for a line that is not strong
enough to hold that kind of
wait um but at least that line was
better than this from Nikki Haley who
had a little uh comeback for uh Vivic
ramaswami let's watch
that this is infuriating because Tik Tok
is one of the most dangerous social
media apps that we could have and what
you've got I honestly every time I hear
you I feel a little bit Dumber for what
you say because I can't believe they
hear you got a Tik Tock situation what
they're doing is these 150 million
people are on Tik Tok that means they
can get your contacts they can get your
financial information they can get your
emails they can get text messages they
can get this is this is very important
for our they're do this is very
important for our you've gone and you've
help China bu make medic and China not
America you're now wanting kids to go
and get on the social media that's
dangerous for all of us you went and you
were in business with the Chinese that
gave Hunter Biden $5 million we can't
trust you we can't trust you we can't
have Tik Tok
you have 15 seconds I think
excuse you have 15 seconds Mr rameswari
thank you I think we would be better
served as a Republican party if we're
not sitting here hurling personal
insults and actually have a legitimate
debate about policy okay uh so every
time I hear you I feel dumber and the
first problem is that that insult could
really go either way so are you saying
he's so much smarter than you
that you feel dumb like do you mean you
feel dumb in the way that I feel dumb
when I listen to someone explain quantum
physics because you could read it that
way and and I I think that Ros Swami
missed an opportunity for some kind of
comeback like that I mean of course he
goes to yeah I mean the safest thing is
to go with let's put the personal
attacks aside you don't it's personal
attacks let's not that's the safest move
you know it's it's fine um but he could
have gone the other way and say look I'm
sorry that you feel dumb uh have you
tried Tried reading a book uh you know
I'm I'm sorry you feel that way could
have gone that way
um but but either way this is just uh
from from Haley it's a it's a cliche
childish line it's a kind of line that
was clever on the internet in the year
2008 which ironically is the last
election where a Nikki Haley candidacy
would have been
viable which come to think of it he I
mean r romic could have also said that
would have been a good line um as for
disantis I thought his best moment was
this one it's a it's a small moment um
but his best moment came at the
moderator's worst
moment and now the setup for this qu
this question that we'll play for you or
or it's not even a question the setup
for this activity that they give uh the
candidates is good the setup is good
because the setup is that there are too
many people in the primary there are too
many people in the field so why are you
all there that's a valid question like
when you got someone who's still in the
primary and and they you know and if the
vote was today uh they would get 0 one%
of the vote or whatever it's totally
valid to say why are you here what are
you doing you're not gonna win stop Doug
bergam you're not stop well anyone could
wi no not anyone can win you're not GNA
win we all know you're not going to win
okay you're just you're not it's not
going to
happen so it's a valid question what are
you actually doing you're obviously not
going to win so what are you at why are
you
here why don't you drop out and and if
you if you especially in a primary like
this because if you're a candidate and
if you think that Trump is the right
nominee if you think he's a good
candidate then why don't you drop out
and rally around him or if you think
that he's a terrible candidate then why
don't you drop out and rally around the
only guy who has even the slightest
chance of beating him which would be Dan
santis so it's a good question but they
turned it in to a game show instead and
here's how that
went none of you have indicated that
you're dropping out so which one of you
on stage tonight should be voted off the
island please use your marker to write
your choice on the notepad in front of
you 15 seconds starting out of the
people on the stage should
be with all due respect I mean we're
here like you know we're happy to debate
but I think that that's disrespectful to
my fellow competitors no want nobody
wants to participate let's do some
questions let's talk about the future of
the country
I'll
answer now the great thing is that's the
right answer from Dan santis and the
great thing is you see if you watch that
clip again you can see a couple of the
guys Chris Christie was about to do it
so he was told write your answer like a
child write your answer draw write your
answer and draw a little picture draw
draw a picture of who you think
shouldn't be on the stage and Chris
Christie is like he's grabbing the pen
he's got it he's about he's sitting that
he's about to write an answer down and
then Dan santis says we're not doing
that that's stupid and and then you can
see Chris chrisy put the pen down say
that's dumb we're not doing that I was
going to do it anyway I wasn't even
writing that I was writing something
else I was just I was writing a note to
myself I just happened it's got nothing
to do with what's happening
here um so that's good for to say
decisive serious and and you know what
because he's the best part is he's
smacking down our ridiculous
media and that is when he's at his best
it's a great moment it's a total
embarrassment for Fox the whole thing
was embarrassing for fox fox embarrasses
itself every single day it's a it's a
it's a joke of an organization
completely um um but this in particular
and you know the thing is a lot of
people complain that
fox they said that fox botched the
debate because they were they were
letting the candidates argue too much
and it was getting out of control but
the problem as always was the opposite
of that the problem as always with I
will I will never complain if I watch
the debate I will never complain about
hearing from the
moderators too infrequently okay I'm
never going to say that I want to hear
from the moderators more if the
moderators never said a damn word if
they just that would at least be better
than this if they just said okay uh you
guys are all run for
president tell us why you should be
president you have two hours and then
they sat there and it's like whatever
happens that would be better than what
we do now so the the the real problem is
that they injected themselves too
much and for an example of that I want
you to watch this moment uh with uh
ramas Swami watch 10 points million
students in over 18,000 Public Schools
Nationwide have the ability to change
their identity without parental
notification Governor chrisy told Stuart
last week that he would pass a federal
law to protect parental rights would you
try to do the same I have to be very
clear about this transgenderism
especially in kids is a mental health
disorder we have to acknowledge the
truth of that for what it is I met two
young women early in this campaign
speciically on parental rights in school
parents have the right to know and you
know what the hypocrisy of this is even
New Hampshire failed to actually get
pass a piece of legislation here the
very people who say that this increases
the risk of suicide are also the ones
saying that parents don't have the right
to know about that increased risk of
suicide and I'm sorry it is not
compassionate to affirm a kid's
confusion that is not compassion that is
cruelty I met two young women Khloe and
Katie early in this campaign who were in
their 20s now regret getting double
mastectomies and a hysterectomy one of
them will never have children and the
fact that we allowed that to happen in
this country is barbaric so I will ban
genital mutilation or chemical castion
under the AG parents have absolutely you
TR to pass a federal law that says
parents parents should have that right
we are going to require States
absolutely have to follow that through b
follow yes you okay what are you doing
like shut up and let him finish his
thought for God sake he's this is is the
he's not dodging this is the opposite of
dodging the question this is actually
giving you more he's he's going so if
you're afraid of the transgender
question which plenty of candidates on
that stage would be and are um uh you're
not you're not going to answer and the
first thing you're say isn't going to be
transgenderism is a mental health
disorder um that's what you say if
you're not you're actually trying to say
more about the question and um he's
trying to say something important here
and he's it's not dancing around the
issue he's in the middle of trying to
call for a federal ban on child gender
Transitions and that's something where
you would think you let him talk and let
him finish and then that's an
interesting point of view for a
president to have right I mean that's
that's a big policy uh promise so let
him say that shut up for a second let
him say what he's saying he's running
for president you're not we don't care
about your opinion we care about
his um and then once he said that then
you could go to everyone else on the
stage and and let them uh weigh in on
that particular
topic which which is more which is more
important by the way the parental rights
thing it's important but if that's all
you're talking about it's a Dodge if
that when it when it comes to the trans
discussion and gender
transitions if all you want to talk
about is parental rights that is a Dodge
you are dodging the real issue because
it's not parental rights obviously
important but it's it's even if parents
consent to
it is it okay to do this to a kid that's
the real fundamental question is it okay
to do this to a kid regardless of what
the parents
say it if all you're doing is talking
about parental rights then what you're
trying what you're implying is that uh
yeah if the parents are okay with it
then go
ahead so this is what moderators do and
uh uh so it was just Dan santis wins Fox
loses and the American people for the
most part don't care because these
debates um the way they're run are
pointless uh which also makes it hard
for anyone to actually win because they
don't really get a chance like there's
not really an opportunity to have a real
moment or to do anything interesting or
say anything important because we see
what happens you try to say something
important and you get cut off but time's
up that's it let's up move on next
person hey YouTube thanks for listening
to the show if you'd like access to my
full show with no ads you should go to
dailywire.com and use promo code Walsh
to get two months free on all annual
plans see you there